[Music]
thousands of Texans will pay their
respects this afternoon to President
George Herbert Walker Bush when his body
is carried by train for his burial after
the funeral at st. Martin's Episcopal
Church in Houston the train will travel
70 miles to the former president's final
resting place in College Station the
trip is expected to take about two hours
and 25 minutes
chip Reid shows us where the train will
end its journey we'll have probably the
element leaders over there high school
seniors s Annette Ruiz and Abel Martinez
are preparing for President George HW
Bush's farewell ride through his
cherished Texas countryside whenever the
Train does pass by I'll call them all to
attention they will join about 7,000
other students along the tracks in
Spring Texas I think we're all a little
bit nervous we don't want to do mess
anything up the 17 year olds never knew
mr. Bush as their president but want to
commemorate him for his public service
we'd like to honor Bush 41 because he's
done so much for Texas our core values
are integrity first service before self
and excellence in all we do that second
core value service before self really
resonates with what George HW Bush did
where he helped a lot of the community
in the nation back in 2005 Union Pacific
Railroad honored President Bush the 41st
president by giving this locomotive the
number 41 41 and painting it to resemble
Air Force One
later today this very locomotive will
pull the train that will carry President
Bush to his final resting place
a locomotive that President Bush himself
once got a chance to take for a spin
someone called this rail for for Scott
Moore is senior vice president at Union
Pacific Railroad and worked with
President Bush on his 1992 campaign
there's a long history in this country
of fallen leaders going to their final
resting place by train fallen leaders
including Abraham Lincoln Franklin
Delano Roosevelt and senator bobby
kennedy have been carried by train to
their burial sites to give people across
the country a chance to pay their
respects but the tradition hasn't been
practiced since the funeral of President
Eisenhower nearly 50 years ago when the
Bush family asked us to provide a train
for this particular event obviously the
uniqueness of having a locomotive
painted and honor this president was the
obvious choice it's an opportunity for
people here in Texas and early across
the country to take one last look at
this great man in a movement to a spinal
resting place so this is where you and
your friends will be when that train
comes about 60 miles down the tracks and
Hayes is hosting a farewell party for
the former president I'll probably be
sad but on the other hand I'll be happy
that I got to know him and be a docent
at his museum for 20 years office of
George Bush the 80 year old has
volunteered more than 7,500 hours at his
Presidential Library on the campus of
Texas A&M when you're doing all this
volunteer work do you feel you're doing
it for President Bush yes yes yes he's
met the president while volunteering and
received this photograph that she now
treasures what was he like when he would
come by the museum very down-to-earth
and just just to read he'd come over and
talk to everybody and just just really a
neat person she says Thursday's
procession will be a celebration of his
life what do you think you're going to
be feeling when that train passes by oh
I think my hearts can be beating very
heavily but
I I'll try to hold my emotions and be
happy like he'd want me to be now the
train has almost a dozen cars for Busch
family and friends and in the middle of
the Train is a converted baggage car
painted red white and blue and it will
have plexiglass sides and it will be
brightly lit inside so that people can
see the casket of President Bush as it
slowly passes by on its way here to his
final resting place
Nora historic indeed and what a sight to
see chip thank you so much